hello everyone bet you didn't expect me
to come from there welcome to another
video what's that t-series have been in
the lead for the past couple of days
[Music]
really pros who cares about sub-camp
anyway honestly so lame this is all just
a troll it was a big troll I said it I
don't care about numbers I don't care I
really don't care
should we just jump into it skedaddle
article 13 oh god of great can Kim
something good come out of this life huh
what goddamn they just did that guess
why I'm in Japan I think that the
annoying part is that no one knows
what's gonna happen if it was clear the
rules going like okay now you can't do
this or okay blah blah blah it would be
okay but now there's so much doubt and
confusion so I would wait a little bit
before we go full-on panic but I am 100%
moving country [ __ ] says it's a subtle
move I could have posted this alright I
saw this mean long ago very long ago
that's why I didn't scrap that when I
saw this me hi Felix I'm 9 years old the
perfect age sounds weird for me to say
from Norway and I'm in the hospital your
content mails me happy in the darkest of
times and I just wanted to say thank you
brofist
hope you're doing well soon tat one guy
all the best
the 9 year olds are rooting for you I
said we're no nine year old dare to
stand in March
absolute power move well done random
Indian guy well first of all because of
the hue tube algorithm ice don't tell
him but the 90 million Club merch is out
now and it's looking hell of sick and it
get look at it it's very nice look very
cool
Wikipedia changing the most subscribe
YouTube channel
for the hundred and twenty second time
this week hey well you know it's gonna
be the last when we take our Felix
should do a 12-hour stream at ninety
nine million so we can witness the sub
count passing 100 mill that is a great
idea but let's get real here ste series
I've already passed let's just
acknowledge the situation it's over okay
you've might as well buy the 90 million
Club merch now because we ain't never
gonna get to a hundred this is sad I'm
crying and shaking Ben Shapiro destroys
marble what if Avengers endgame it's
just three hours of famous teaching us
agriculture it ain't much but it's all a
survivor you feel the wave part about
this is I don't actually know if this is
real or fake
holy crap have fun I know where this is
from where is this from it does look
strikingly like him very nice shingles
is that a subreddit shame what a damn
shame someone needs some create shin
goes right freaking now one subscriber
set up 91 million set up I recorded that
on my iPhone I remember okay
stop making fun of my setup alright the
quality is the best okay yeah everyone's
saying that the quality is better here
in Japan oh there we go look at that
Felix camera quality Felix camera
quality in Japan wow I think you guys
are probably right this pride probably
used the wrong settings I need to change
it when I started OBS here it said like
hey do you want to use the best setting
for streaming or recording I'm like well
recording me when I don't skip a pip I
add because that money is my wedding
gift to Felix and Marcia it
mugs but it's honest work thank you so
much found an old photo with me with
Felix and Marcia what's great to meet
you see this is what people don't
realize that's how I look like
that's my appearance JK Rowling is big
gay being gay isn't a choice it's an
involuntary thing that happens when JK
Rowling decides it's your time JK
Rowling's the ruler of gays Hey look you
found me again Jesus Christ
huge sighting today in Tokyo as I am 188
I can confirm he's at least 180 the best
height of all time I'm not insecure
about my height though I didn't see his
Footwear keep it that way far away
respect his holiday since then I took a
picture of him makes no sense sorry have
a nice trip in Japan I like this photo
cuz it looks like might say is
completely dead inside I'm like showing
my phone to her me like hey might see a
look at this meme and she's just like oh
god no please
not another one my [ __ ] looks like she's
having Vietnam flashbacks as a fellow
Italian I can confirm that's the face we
make when we see overcooked F's in the
chance for mine to everyone to the range
this is the Marvel movie I want to see
if dr. Phil is not in the Marvel
Cinematic endgame a speeding beating up
vanish I don't know how they're possibly
gonna defeat him then one mean to rule
them all
he always joked that there's one mean
that's just gonna surpass them all one
superior mean that's gonna transcend the
human race could it be could it be
Ricardo Morelos only time will tell but
so far my god he's defeated Death
himself and me review doing my part in
Christian Sun No
in the log of the region Bros the earth
should not be hotter than Shrek yeah I
agree
well done Norway surprised me I am blue
shirt kid like I play a lot of fortnight
you are the color Thank You blue shirt
kid for hosting me review one of our
finest meme review so far oh god no oh
god oh god no I didn't think it would
come to this don't look at this this is
fake memes that's it these shoes they
look like they have a big plateau but
really my feet are touching the ground
it's just an illusion like an optical
illusion
the soul is actually this big on the
inside so thank you
yes 180 confirmed alright glide glide we
got that out of the way
EU faves means in Europe you know I'm
something of a Japanese myself I mean it
came at a good time you did it I guess I
just have to stay here it's either that
or quit so I don't know man
t-series we're the most subscribed
channel PewDiePie man this war has been
going on for like six months now I can't
believe it's still happening oh god no
oh god oh god it hurts
I can't look at it it's first to 100
million P series you ain't won nothing
yet
that's right I spit on you
he was making his feel at home with his
usual quality while he is in Japan I'm
so thoughtful you guys are why
can you imagine what my camera at home
feels like I used the exact same camera
because I brought it here then how is
the quality better in Japan this makes
zero sense you can't make it to the Y on
a calculator me sit how do you even make
this that's really though well done
normal wasabi what women think men want
what men really want
I cannot read this meme and pretend that
I'm okay with it
okay there are also women watching this
channel that are also very much wanting
to get the hundred million now I can't
speak for all women but this is exactly
what they want and this is what they
only want 100 million alright Marvel
infinity war it's the most ambitious
crossover event in history
me oh god this meme never dies does it
but there's two blue shirt kids Nani
appears telling me there will be a
brofist that a hundred million me at a
hundred million it's not even gonna
compare okay it's gonna be the ultimate
one punch experience of your life you
won't live through this bro fish you
don't understand dude
falou ready sad this is a really sad
episode is it there it feels weird hey
this is the first love why I record
where we're not technically winning sand
just sad it smash like if you were also
sad can we show this man some love oh I
actually saw this this morning I posted
on Twitter it's amazing it really suits
today's episode doesn't he feeling - it
doesn't
[Music]
[Applause]
okay thank you for watching another
episode of the why keep the memes coming
that's the only thing keeping much alive
at this moment a hundred mil is coming
check out the 90 million merch and I see
you browse keys on the hosts keys
brofist at a hundred million and that
evolution of dance video
[Music]
I got the here is blue
what super simulators becoming relevant
no no don't leave
no please sponsor Eagle please do
something yes this game is still
relevant god dammit
[Music]